Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Kindergarten. Now I'm going to try this again
and this time I'm not going to be stupid about what I'm doing.
Not that I was stupid about what I'm doing before, because it was kind of a situation where the world was entirely against me.
and I didn't have any idea what I was doing!
SO!
I'm going to go into this world without the money that I don't have and I'm going to start talking to other people.
Cindy: Hey there cutie, I'm Cindy.  Wanna be my boyfriend?
Mark: Sure! Okay! Alright!
Cindy: HEH! That's what I like to hear and we'll totally be the cutest couple in school, but first you have to do something for uh.
[Sad Music] ISN'T OUR LOVE ENOUGH? HAVEN'T I GIVEN ENOUGH TO YOU? I PULLED MY HEART OUT
..whatever
"Ha ha ha, that's cute, but no it isn't. You're gonna have to prove it to me."
Let's see.
How do I do that?
"You see that girl over there? That's Lily. She is by far the ugliest, nastiest girl you will ever meet."
"I want you to take this gum and stick it in her hair for me during morning time. Got it?"
That's mean, but OH I'M DESPERATE
(Sad Music) OH I'M SO LONELY AND DESPERATE PLEASE LOVE ME (we love you mark)
okay I'll do it
"Oh yay this is gonna be so great. She'll finally get what she deserves, just like her brother did for dumping me." (Was he much better?)
WOAH
"Come find me for morning time after you're done."
What happened to her brother?
"You haven't heard? He went missing. His disappearance totally stole the thunder from my dog Biscuit going missing."
"I guess everyone just cares more about him than they do about me."
What?? Your dog went missing too??
"Yeah I brought her in for show and tell, but the janitor said dogs aren't allowed so he took her."
"Apparently she escaped from his closet and they couldn't find her."
Maybe I could find your dog instead?
"Hm, interesting proposal.  I do miss Biscuit.  The question is, do I love Biscuit more than I hate Lily?"
You love Biscuit more!
"Uh, no. No, I definitely hate Lily more."
Oh.
"Yeah, Lily is actually a despicable person and her existence bothers me. Don't worry about Biscuit."
"Just put that gum in her hair during morning time and talk to me afterwards."
Ooookay.  Alrighty then.
Man, kindergarten is a vicious nightmare land of politics and espionage.
Oh hello!
O-ho
I didn't know that the janitor was over here.
Hi.
"How you doing there sonny? Don't mind the ole janitor here.  Just sweeping up after you silly cretans.  Sweepy, sweepy, sweepy."
*laughs creepily*
That's a mop.
"AH! So it is."
You're also mopping the sidewalk.
"I'LL BE MOPPING YOUR BLOOD OFF IT IF YOU DON'T SKEDADDLE"
I don't wanna skedaddle!
I DON'T WANNA SKEDADDLE
"I'm a man of my word!"
You're going to kill me?
OW OW OW ow owwwow *splushing noises*
WHY IS EVERYONE OKAY WITH THAT?
WHY IS EVERYONE OKAY WITH THAT??
You know, that's just mean and rude and okay I'm going to talk to Lily first because Lily doesn't seem so stupid.
"Oh. Um, hey I'm Lily. You probably heard about what happened to my brother."
I haven't.
"You haven't?  It's been all over the news. He went missing a few days ago."
Sorry to hear about that.
"Thanks. That makes you one of the few people who even seems to care. Ever since he went missing people either ignore me or insult me"
(In a low voice) "Cindy's been trying to put gum in my hair"
Why?
"I don't know! But if I were you, I'd stay away from her. She's really mean."
Thanks for the tip, I-I guess.
Hello!
"I'm Monty if you need something, come talk to me. Odds are I can get it for you for the right price."
"What I need and what I sell changes throughout the day, so come see me often"
"Here's what's for sale."
Uhh...I can get a skroowdriva
"Got this sucker off the Janitor for a steal. It's weird that he's willing to sell me tools provided to the school."
"But I ain't complaining. It'll run ya $1"
Okay pleasure doing business with ya!
Okay, what else ya got?
I'm gonna get the cigarettes, cause I need those.
"Never took ya for a bad apple. There's only a couple left in the pack, but it's at a discount."
"You can have it for a buck ($1)"
"Just don't go showing 'em to anybody! It could get us both in trouble."
Understood! What can I do for ya?
I'm good! Thank you!
What do you have to say about this conundrum?
"I'm Jerome, I don't think you're cool enough to talk to me"
Whatever jerk. (offended) Alright, fine then!
TEACHER! Jerome's a jerk!
I'm Misses Applegate. I have been well endowed
huh-ho with HUGE tracks of teaching qualities...You sure have!
Alrighty then, I guess the only way to talk to somebody is by going- well I guess I could take this
Yeah I do. Yes I do
Isn't our love enough?
Uhhh....why?
Alright fine. I'm sold, what do I do?
Alright, sure. Yeah. Okay. I'll do that.
*Mark noises* adaday
*More Mark noises* ababay
You hate Lilly more. Yeah, Lilly is a despicable person. Okay I get it, I get it
Then I talk to Nugget here
Whoa! I'll be your friend!!
What is your offering? I only have friendship
Heh, perhaps that is all Nugget needs. You may have Nugget's nuggets. It signifies our friendship.
Thank you! Do not consume the nugget of friendship, for with it's digestion, to is our friendship digested.
Good, Nugget will see you later friend.
Okay, no more talking now. Okay.
Well who do I talk to then?!
Who do I talk to?
How ya doin'? Okay..alright bye then!
Guh...g-goodbye I guess
I guess this is goodbye
I don't know what im doing here but okaayyyy!!
Hello....want some cigarettes?
Woah! I've been robbing kids so I could buy these from Monty. Thank's a bunch! You can have this Monstermon card.
It's one of my favorites. Okay!
*bell rings* Okay children it's time to start the day! Everybody head inside for morning time.
Alright, that's a different way, I guess I'm not gonna get any pills this time
It's time for you to pick your buddies for morning time, or you can be sad, pathetic, and alone. As long as you're the best "you" you can be.
Okay
*Mark sings with tune* do do do do do bah buh bo be dah not gonna put gum in your hair
Oh, I dont' really do the whole morning buddy thing, okay fine.
Here you go!!
Did you just? Oh you did, you put gum in my hair. Oh..I didn't mean to!
Cindy put me up to this! Well I don't even care, leave me alone.
I didn't mean to do that.   I didn't mean to do that
Hello
Did you do it? Oh my gosh you totally did! Wow what happened? What did she say? Did she cry?I bet she totally cried!
She cried.
Yes, I'm so happy! You can be my morning buddy which also make you my boyfriend.
As my boyfriend you get the honor of playing house with me! I'll meet you over at the doll house!
I'll be home soon honey.
Ahh this is weird! A little weird okay...
Welcome home husband! I hope work wasnt too hard because you're going to be making dinner tonight.
Why do I have to make dinner?
Because I've been so busy maintaining the house. And I *Mark noises*
Have you been drinking again? Haha, yes dear!
Well at least you're being honest with me, AND more importantly yourself. You have a problem.
Yes dear
I want to call your sponsor and tell him about it
I also want you to give me money to buy a new purse and handle the trauma and PTSD you're causing me.
Yes dear, I don't have the money for that. You're not?
You might want to reconsider that. Why? Because otherwise, you might get hurt.
Is that? nah ha, I don't know, is that a knife??
It's my pretty pink pocket knife. Now give me some money and help me calm down.
I don't have enough! That's a shame. You showed some promise...oh well!
We don't *stab* OWW!!
I DID, I JUST WAS TRYING TO BE A GOOD HUSBASND I THOUGHT THAT I WAS GONNA BE BLEGHH
Alright, fine then! I guess I'll sell something before I so say "hi" to you!
Alright, I'm gonna sell, no not that I don't want that. No not that, I wanna sell something!
I gotta whole bunch of shit but I cant sell it. Alright
Aww now I can't get something from the racks because I didn't get the teacher DRUGS!!
*Please don't do drugs*
Nugget can you give me anything?
*sighs in frustration*
Alright fine. Nugget needs a magnifying glass but I cant get a magnifying glass.
Don't go snooping around, alright then.
OH no no no no
You can't just leave class without a pass.
Oh, can I use the bathroom?
I don't know CAN YOU?? Oh you are a bitch -_-
MAY I use the bathroom? Of course, now that you asked correctly. Here's the bathroom pass.
Gee thanks, just be back soon!
Okay! I need to find some mooo- hi.
Not so fast there little dude, I'ma need to see your hall pass before I can let you by.
Here's my pass! Okay, I'll let you pass, but I can't let you go any further than the bathroom
That's fair.
oh, ho-ho, what ya gonna go about it huh?
NERD!! WHAT YA GONNA DO ABOUT IT NERD!!
Alright fine then. You're pretty big for a kindergartner.
OOOOOOoooooohhhh....hohohohohohoho
For some reason I though the music woulda changed but I guess not.
HI, heh heh, what's going on there boy? What's in those baaaaags??
What bags? I don't see no bags.
You're kidding right? OOHH THESE bags hehehe
Nothing for you to worry your stupid little head about. Now run along, hehehe
It's bleeding!
Ohh? Yes..the uhh...bleeding
Say, did you know I'm required by lay to stay at least one mop's length away from children at all times.
uhh.....how did that judgement get passed down??
*creepy Mark* It's a long story...but it ends with someone at the end of a mop!
Sounds riveting! It is, but that's a tale for another time.
I'm..morbidly curious.
hehe, me too. That's what got me into this mess in the first place.
Anyway I don't think it would be appropriate for me to tell someone of your age
But it's okay for me to see a bloody bag in a bin?
Righto! You sure are chipper young sport. Here, take this nickel and buy yourself a bar of chocolate.
A nickel won't cut it. What do you mean a nickel won't cut it? It's gonna have to cut it or I'm gonna cut you!
Chocolate is more expensive than a nickel!
oh, in that case I'll let the old lunch lady know to give you chocolate at a price you would have seen back in my day
Before the whole...mop incident. How bout that? Okay!
Good. Now skedaddle.
Alright goodbye, I guess I'm gonna get some cheap
chocolate. Door won't budge. Someone must
be in there. Alrighty then.
I can hear someone grunting on the other
side of the door.( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
It must be use.
Aaaah, gross
This toilet is disgusting. There's no way I can use it.
Gross. Well there was no point
in me coming in here, well
I didn't even get a nickel out of that.
What was the point of *Mark noises* i-i-i-it all
see. "HEY
don't go messin' around with those bags" Alright
fine then. Just gonna be on my way
Mr.Janitor, sir, I got me a
discount for lunch
chocolate. "Oh, you're back!"
Yes I am. "I'll take that
bathroom pass now, go back to your morning time."
okaaay
alrighty then. Don't know
what to doooo. Huh
Okay, so if I put the...
well. Yup. I did that.
aaaalright. Well I
did that. I don't know if I wanna play house, because
I think it's gonna end up in me murdering.
being murdered, cause I don't have enough
money. Alright. Okay.
N-oh boy.
Oooh boy.
Yes dear.
Think I left something in the car. Alright
byyye. Because I dont know
if I wanna do that. Alright (so many alrights)
Teacher. Can I not be Cindy's
Partner. Idontwanna
okay. Alright, okay. I-I would
kinda wanna be an outcast loser, but that'd be nice
okay, alright
Hullo. Welcome home.
Yes dear. uuuuh.
No, I'm just tired. mmm
No, I'm just tired. oh
Is that a bleh
*laughing* breathalyzer? "You bet
it is, and if you blow so much as a point O one
I'm calling your sponsor." I'll take
the test. "Good. Blow"
point three t-  I didn't
I DIDN'T DO THE that
is not be a fATHER?
ah, ah, I, "well while you were in
prison, it's probably not yours
I'm sorry, I guess I have my own set of problems
to deal with" But, I *mark noises*
*more mark noises* I wanna
divorce! I- "You're right
this isn't working out. What, do we
do now?" Go spend a night with your mother.
"Okay I guess that's fair
I'll call ya tomorrow, hope we can sort this out amicably.
Wow, that was the most fun I've had playing
house *laughing* in a while. You're gonna
make a splendid boyfriend, I want you to have lunch with me."
Great! I'll see you then!
what version
of house do you come from?!
okaaay.
At least I made to LUNCH
ALIVE which is nice.
hope to get to the end of the day this time. ay
hey lunch lady! Can I have a
chalkoolat? Let's see got any
th- oh not that. Got anything
in it. nah nah nah, don't want that
nah nah, got anything else? Alright.
awe, why is it so expensive?
wait, I'll take the ch-
*Mark noises* cheaper
"Oh you must be
the janitors new little friend
yup, he said you were a good kid.
I can let ya have a char bok
*Mark stutters* lehtchar char be char of bocolate.
for a nickel." yeah.
"You enjoy that then kiddo
have a nice day." Alright I got a chocolate bar
I guess that's good. Can I sell the chocolate
bar or do I need it for something?
Huh. Sell.
I got a chocolate bar.
"How did you manage to get that? It's
almost worth it's weight in gold!  Emphasis
on the almost. I'll give you five dollars for
that."  DEAL! Deal! It's
a steal deal! Alright.
I wanna buy
some. Oh, you just got food, I don't need
that. Alright whatever.
Alright cool. I got the, won a profit. Alright. (alrightX4)
Hi, Cindy, hiiii,
Do I need to talk to Janitor about the baaags
Biscuit balls.
oooooohhhhhhhh
I don't wanna mess with- I don't want
any. I-I just don't want
any. I don't wanna deal with you.
I wanna be Cindy's boyfriend. (no Amy is better)
"Oh hey boyfriend! I saved you
a spot. Go get something to eat and come
sit with me." I have a nugget.
I don't think I should eat that nugget.
It might be a bad
idea to eat that. I'm gonna eat that nugget. "Oh good! I was just thinking about. Oh darn-it
My stupid mother packed me something that's not vegan
She knows I'm all vegan right now.
God, that women is insufferable.
Hey, sweetie would you be a darling and go get me
something vegan? Yeah you know
Um, like
I don't know exactly what it means, but I know
It's good, so just ask around and see if you can find something
vegan. Oh, and the slop isn't vegan."
Okaaay. I know the
biscuit balls are vegan *laughs*
Biscuit balls?
What's in them?
Alright, how much are they?
Why would Cindy want to try one?
You're being creepy about it.
Did you drug it?
She wants something vegan.
ahhh
alright
I'll give you the biscuit ball for free. Don't worry hehe, it's vegan.
I'll also throw in one of those Monstermon cards.
Okay!
Okay. Ayyee Cindy it's vegan!
What did you get me?
This thing!
That's vegan? Are you sure?
Iiiii'm not sure about anything Cindy up into this point!
Umm...okay I trust you, *munch munch*
Hey, that's pretty good. It kinda reminds me of my d-dog HUUH
AH HA
AHHHH-righty then
I fed her her dog!
That is NOT vegan!
Im gonna go ahead and point out that is...
Thats not vegan
You're being so good to me today
You're probably the most well-trained boyfriend I've ever met
I should use you for someting at recess. Hm... I have an idea
Im really liking the way Lily wears that gum
But maybe we could put somethig else in there
What do you mean?
Jerome was telling me how the janitor has all sorts of
gross stuff in his closet
*incomprehensible noises*
Alrighty then
You dont have to worry about that
Look what I have!
You have the key?
Yep, girl has her ways
Im gonna head over and pay off the lunch lady
so you can get going on that nasty closet.
What about the hall monitor?
Oh that silly boy. He'll be in the bathroom having a
cigarette.
Just dont go in there and you'll be fine.
Okay, listen for the bell when you're in there.
The janitor will come back shortly after it rings
*laughter* so get out as soon as possible.
Lets do this!
Alright!
You're good to go, hurry back!
Okay! Im goin I'm going Cindy loo hoo
I don't know why im going for this but im going for it!
*bell ring*
Ahhh im gonna get that monster man card.
Ohhh unscrew it, gimme that
Uh oh, hey you shoudn't be in here its recess time go out
and play.
Ohhhhhh
Well that was too quick.
Why'd that happen?
What the hell happened!
Well I didn't do nothin.
Well alrighty then.
Go play while you're still young and thin
Alright
What do ya got
Monstermon card
Woooooah
I don't have enough money for that
Alright
I don't want anything I think
Just gonna go on my way
Well
I know he did it, I don't know why but I know he did.
You talking about the principal?
The murdurus principal?
Theres a red glint in his eyes, creepyyy.
Alrighty then
Well what did you get?
Lets see
Im not ready to show you yet I think.
Maybe
Im not 100% sure about that.
Nugget, that is a gigantic hole...
in the ground...
that you have dug.
Behold! The Nugget cave.
It is a very deep and very dark
What secrets does it hold?
Do you wanna find out?
SURE!
Oooooh
*thump*
*soft laughter*
*laughing* I didn't
I didn't wanna do that!
Thats not what I wanted to do.
Thats the opposite of what I wanted to do.
Okay. Alright. Hello
Get out of here I'm busy.
You dont look busy.
I am bu...
Oh whats the point
Its no fun being the bully when no  matter how many
kids you beat up my dad still isn't coming back.
Little bit sentimental there
I miss everything about him, even the way he used to
drink excessively
OH
Here?
A breathalyzer?
Aww its just like the one my mom used to force my dad to use
Thanks buddy
AH
Okay!
Awh this is sad
AH
Its sad
Alright
Your welcome
Ahh I'm sad now
Alright
Behold-
Noh I don't wanna
N-n
No I don't think I will
No one has ever not loved the Nugget cave
I'm not goin
Oh you'll go
One way or another
You'll go
I don't think I'll go
Don't bother me kid, I'm trying to figure this out
Its this riddle about theses stupid duck things.
Appairently if you shake them in the right order somethings supposed to happen
Whats the riddle?
Go twice the ducks that's farthest south.
Then two blue before red
After return to the first duck then blue
Get it wrong and you're dead
Okay so yellow, yellow, blue, blue, red, yellow... blue
Okay
Okay!
Yellow!
Yellow
Blue
Red
Yellow
Blue
Alright!
Okay! Thats weird magic that happened there
Not 100% sure why
But that happened
Alrighty then
Theres a monstermon card laying on the ground here
Yay!
I'm great at what I do at stuff and things
Alright I'm gonna tell Cindy that I don't got nothing cuz I don't
I didn't grab anything
Nothing? You didn't grab anything?
What the hell are you even good for?
I hope you die! We're threw!
Im sorry you feel that way about me.
I dont feel lke thats- okay alright nevermind then
Alright
Okay everyones weird here and I don't know how to
leave
How do I leave?
Well I don't know how I did it, but I think I reached a dead end.
Ah
Reh-
This game is in early acess so I think
I found a way to not get to where I need to go
So I think
I think thats the end of what I can do here
which is a damn shame because I'm gonna lose all the
progress that I made
SOOOOOO
Okay then! I guess thats no good!
So that is the end of this episdoe here
I'm sorry I didn't make any more prgress
I just dont wanna have to die to be able to get any farther
So thank you everybody so much for watching
Let me know how I'm doing in Kindergarten. I have a feeling not very well
but I'm enjoying myself question mark?
SO thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always, I will see YOU...
in the next video
BYE BYE